y los seres humanos hemos sabido por
miles de años
solamente observando nuestro entorno que
existen diferentes sustancias y esas
diferentes sustancias tienen propiedades
distintas
uno podría lo mejor reflejar la luz de
alguna forma o no reflejar la obtener
algún color o alguna a partir de alguna
temperatura son líquidos gases o sólidos
pero también empezamos a observar cómo
reaccionan el uno con el otro aquí hay
algunas imágenes de algunas sustancias
por ejemplo este es carbón en su forma
de grafito este de aquí es plomo y este
de aquí es oro y estas imágenes que les
estoy compartiendo las obtuve de esta
página web
entonces todas estas están en su forma
sólida y también sabemos que a veces
vemos cierto tipo de aire digamos
partículas de cierto aire que según el
tipo de partículas que estamos
observando por ejemplo carbón oxígeno
nitrógeno parece tener distintas
propiedades o por ejemplo hay otras que
pueden ser líquidas que si elevan la
temperatura suficientemente puedes
obtener del oro del plomo formas
líquidas o si quemas este carbón puedes
obtenerlo en una forma gaseosa rompiendo
toda su estructura así que todas estas
cosas que la humanidad ha observado por
miles de años
han llevado a una pregunta natural lo
que solía ser filosófica pero ahorita ya
la podemos resolver y la pregunta es si
sigues rompiendo este carbón digamos en
pedacitos cada vez más pequeños
si las sigues cortando en unidades cada
vez más pequeñas de esta de esta
sustancia podremos encontrar la alguna
mínima que todavía tenga las propiedades
del carbono y la respuesta es sí si se
puede y sólo para entrar en terminología
a todas estas diferentes sustancias que
son puras que tienen las propiedades
específicas a ciertas temperaturas y
reaccionan de cierta forma las llamamos
elementos elementos el carbón es un
elemento el plomo el oro y puedes pensar
que el agua pero en la historia la
regular la gente lo ha referido como un
elemento pero ya sabemos que el agua
está hecho de más sustancias de hecho
está hecho de de oxígeno e hidrógeno
perdón y todas las sustancias puras los
elementos se encuentran en la tabla
periódica por ejemplo aquí tenemos
hidrógeno y carbón
y poco a poco te vas a ir familiarizando
con esto este es oxígeno nitrógeno es de
silicio este por ejemplo de acá es oro
esto es plomo y la unidad básica de
todos estos elementos es el átomo el
átomo
ok así que si sigues rascándole y
tomando cada vez pequeñas partes del
carbón vamos a obtener un en un átomo de
carbón por ejemplo aquí un átomo de oro
en sí si sigues cortando en pedacitos
más pequeños llegarías a una unidad
mínima y que podríamos seguirlo llamando
por ejemplo en este caso plomo y que
siga teniendo las propiedades del plomo
solo para que te des una idea y esto es
algo que realmente me cuesta mucho
imaginar es que los átomos son
increíblemente pequeños terriblemente
pequeños así que en realidad por ejemplo
mi cabello está hecho de carbón más aún
casi todo lo que es parte de los seres
vivos está hecho de carbono así que si
tomas mi cabello mi pelo y es
principalmente carbono si tomas el pelo
que voy a pintar en amarillo digo mi
cabello es negro pero si lo pintara de
negro no lo verías en la pantalla pero
si tomas mi cabello y te preguntas
cuántos átomos de carbono hay
en un corte transversal de mi cabello es
decir cuántos podríamos preguntarnos
cuántos átomos de carbono hay en lo
ancho de mi cabello así que tú podrías
decir oye bueno si ya me dijiste que son
pequeños quizás son miles pero no
realmente tenemos cadenas de millones de
átomos en promedio d
en lo ancho de un cabello en realidad no
es un millón pero da más o menos una
idea de qué tan pequeño es un átomo no
así que imagina poniendo un millón de
partículas a lo largo perdón a lo ancho
de un cabello y que cabe un millón o
digamos el ancho de un cabello es muy
difícil de ver no pero bueno ahora
estaría bien lo que sabemos es que hay
una unidad básica de construcción del
carbono de hecho de cualquier elemento
pero lo que es todavía mejor es que
estos bloques básicos están relacionados
el uno con el otro
por ejemplo el carbón está hecho de
partículas más fundamentales
el oro todos los elementos y de hecho
están definidos por el arreglo de estas
partículas fundamentales y que si
cambias el número de estas partículas
podrías cambiar las propiedades del
elemento o incluso este sí si los reglas
digamos en otro sentido y sólo para
entenderlo vamos a hablar de estas
partículas elementales así que primero
tenemos el protón
tenemos el protón que es y de hecho es
lo que define el no
lo que define a un elemento es el número
de protones que hay en el núcleo y eso
es lo que lo define esto es lo que
define a un elemento y cuando vemos la
tabla periódica de hecho están inscritos
en el orden por número atómico que
literalmente es el número de protones
del elemento así que por definición el
hidrógeno tiene un protón el helio tiene
dos protones el carbón tiene seis
protones no puedes tener carbón con
siete protones porque entonces sería
nitrógeno ya no sería carbono el oxígeno
tiene ocho
y si alguien le agrega un protón ya no
sería oxígeno ya sería flúor así que
esto define el elemento y el número
atómico en el número atómico el número
de protones
hay que recordar que este es el número
que está escrito arriba de cada elemento
el número de protones es igual al número
atómico
al número atómico y pone en ese número
porque es lo que define o caracteriza un
elemento los otros dos los otros dos
elementos partículas perdón que definen
a un átomo son el electrón y el neutrón
y el neutrón
y en el modelo que empezamos a que ya
empezaste a construir en tu cabeza en
este modelo
poco a poco vamos a volverlo un poco más
abstracto de hecho es un poco difícil de
conceptualizar pero bueno tenemos
protones y neutrones en el centro que
son el núcleo del átomo por ejemplo el
carbón tiene 66 protones
y tenemos 6 y el carbono 12 es una
versión del carbono también tiene 6
neutrones
pero eso puede tener y eso quiere decir
que puede tener distintos número de
neutrones pero tenemos el mismo número
de protones no puedes cambiar el número
de protones entonces aquí estoy
dibujando el núcleo del carbono 12
en 696 neutrones ese es el núcleo del
carbono 12 y muchas veces lo escribimos
de esta forma el número de protones
abajo y el número el número del elemento
arriba entonces realmente tenemos 6
neutrones y el total es la suma de los
protones y los neutrones ok entonces
este es el número total de protones y
neutrones dentro del núcleo y este es el
número atómico que está definido por el
número de protones solamente sólo para
acordarnos así que en el centro del
átomo de carbono habrá 2 en partículas 6
protones y 6 neutrones otra versión del
carbono es el carbono 14 baja que tiene
6 protones pero tiene 8 neutrones así
que el número cambiaría
así que el carbono 12 es neutro y les
voy a decir un poquito más de eso en
unos momentos
entonces el carbono va a tener 6
electrones por otro lado entonces una
forma de pensar acerca de esta relación
entre los electrones y el núcleo es que
si imaginas algo digamos estas
partículas moviéndose y zumbando
alrededor nuestro modelo puede poner que
las partículas están orbitando orbitando
alrededor del núcleo no es exactamente
digamos como los planetas alrededor del
sol pero es una forma de pensarlo si
estan zumbando alrededor del núcleo y
eso es porque digo a este nivel de la
física tan pequeño esto realmente es
difícil de entender que es lo que pasa
pero nuestro modelo mental del centro
del átomo del carbono 12
tenemos por aquí en el núcleo y estos
electrones están brincando alrededor del
núcleo y la razón por la que estos
electrones no no se van fuera del núcleo
es que están atados de alguna forma
forman parte de este átomo y es porque
los protones tienen una carga positiva
y los electrones tienen una carga
negativa y esta es una de las
propiedades fundamentales de estas
partículas cuando cuando empezamos a
pensar en la carga que le vamos a
asignar lo que sabemos es que cuando
hablamos de fuerzas electromagnéticas la
mejor forma de pensarlo es qué protones
y electrones debido a que tienen signos
distintos se atraen mutuamente los
neutrones son neutrales justamente así
que ellos simplemente están ahí sentados
en el núcleo y afectan las propiedades
del elemento en hasta cierto punto ajá
pero la razón por la que los electrones
no se van fuera del átomo es porque
están atraídos atraídos al núcleo
y tienen una velocidad increíble es es
muy alta y eso es una de las partes
raras de la física ahora ya que estamos
hablando de lo que el electrón es bueno
lo que podríamos decir es que está
saltando y no se va directo al núcleo
sino que está orbitando alrededor así
que ya mencioné que el carbono 12 perdón
está definido por 6 protones 6 neutrones
y 6 electrones pero otra vez los
electrones pueden interactuar con otros
electrones puede ser que algunos
electrones sean tomados por átomos de
otros elementos y básicamente esto es lo
que le da entendimiento a toda la
química en cómo los electrones están
configurados como los electrones de
otros elementos se configuran y cómo
interactúan cómo interactúan entre el
mismo elemento o con otros elementos
podemos empezar a predecir cómo van a
reaccionar átomos de los mismos
elementos o átomos de elementos
distintos
cómo se unen cómo se atraen cómo se
repelen todos estos así que por ejemplo
y vamos a aprender más de esto en el
futuro es posible para algún átomo en
algún lugar de quitar un electrón de un
de un átomo de carbono por alguna razón
ya hablaremos de ciertos átomos
neutrales
que tienen más afinidad por electrones
que otros así que uno podría quitar de
aquí un electrón de un carbono y
entonces este carbono tendría menos
electrones que protones así que
tendríamos 5 electrones y 6 protones y
tendríamos una carga neta positiva así
que si en este carbono 12 tengo 6
protones 6 electrones las cargas se
cancelan si pierdo un electrón entonces
tengo 5 de estos y 6 positivos nos queda
que tiene una carga positiva todo esto
es vamos a hablarlo más en esta lista de
vídeos porque se va a poner bastante
interesante vamos a llegar a la
construcción del bloque fundamental de
lo que es el átomo y lo que es todavía
mejores es que este bloque fundamental
está hecho de partículas todavía más
elementales que pueden ser
intercambiados por las propiedades de
ciertos átomos y viajar a otros
elementos